as a tourist destination it is certainly
exclusive 250 miles up and traveling at
five miles a second and NASA believes
potential visitors will be queuing up
for a stay on the International Space
Station they made the announcement on
Wall Street a sign of how the private
sector is now vital to the future of the
space race and this offer won't come
cheap our cost is coming down to about
58 million dollars a seat so
theoretically a private astronaut I
would expect the price to be in that
range they'd have to know the two
companies right now that can do it our
Boeing and SpaceX if you look at the
pricing and you add it up back of the
napkin it will be roughly about
thirty-five thousand dollars a night per
astronaut but it won't come with any
Hilton Marriott points but as one of its
astronauts explained this is all about
NASA raising money for its other big
projects transitioning toward this new
model of business is an important step
to enable NASA to move full speed ahead
toward our goal of landing the first
women and the next man on the moon which
a few weeks ago still seem to be the
president's ambition too is tweet today
then confusing on a number of levels for
all of the money we're spending NASA
should not be talking about going to the
moon we did that 50 years ago they
should be focused on the much bigger
things we're doing including Mars of
which the moon is a part defense and
science it's hard for NASA leadership
and everyone in the space program to
really have any trust that what the
administration says it's going to do it
will in fact do in the years ahead and
that's not even getting into what
Congress might decide is important for
the space program we are just weeks away
from that anniversary of the moon
landing NASA wants to be back there in
five years time plenty of private
companies are racing to show they can
take tourists into space before then
NASA says as many as a dozen could be
bound for the space station and if all
goes to plan they could blast off as
soon as next year
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles